last year at this time we ran between
300 to 400 illegal injuries
right now we're at 34 hundreds in the
month of march alone we are currently
averaging almost five illegals an hour
right now crossing the border that's an
hour 24
hours a day seven days a week there is a
rural law in this country we are a
country of immigrants we all welcome
immigration we all do
we've all been beneficiaries of
immigrants in our community but legal
immigrants
sheriffs coming together to share their
concerns about the migrant surge at the
southern border
and as of this tuesday two days ago
more than 23 000 unaccompanied minors
are in u.s custody arizona governor
doug ducey has declared a state of
emergency in his state
deploying an additional 250 national
guard troops
president biden we are getting whiplash
out here
from all the mixed signals president
biden
if you want to stop the disaster that's
unfolding here
and will only get worse
in the coming months you should declare
a national emergency
chad wolf is a former acting dhs
secretary and heritage foundation
visiting fellow
chad thanks for being with me when you
and i have talked in the past we talked
about the ramp up to where we are right
now how would you describe categorize
this moment in time
well again uh we continue to have an
ongoing crisis but it's now becoming a
national tragedy what's occurring
down here at the border you've had over
150
170 000 illegal apprehensions in the
month of march alone and as we heard the
governor just now
those numbers are going to increase as
we get ladder into the months of the
summer
and so again the biden administration
continues to address
the symptoms of this problem and not
going towards the root causes of it
you need to enforce the law and you need
to get serious about border security
and you can continue to care for these
individuals that come into dhs's custody
as they should
but that alone will not solve the
problem so unfortunately
where the federal government won't step
up you have you have governors like
governor abbott and texas governor ducey
in
arizona that are deploying national
guard and their own law enforcement to
the border
and it's a sad state when when governors
have to do that
because the federal government chooses
not to
wow and if they don't you have to ask
the question what happens if the numbers
continue to go
up because they're not plateauing at
this point
well the the system is broken and we
know that because of the number of
unaccompanied alien children over 20 000
53 000 last month of family units
those individuals and those families are
largely being released
a small percentage are being turned
around back to mexico but a lot of them
are being released here into the united
states and so as these numbers grow
the system will continue to be broken
they'll continue to look for additional
facilities how do we take care of them
where are they going uh but it's it's
not going to be enough
i i mean the social services in
different states that they have to be
seeing this influx too that's a part of
the story that maybe we jump to next
but i do want to go here the white house
has finally uh
confirmed that the vice president kamala
harris
will meet with the president of
guatemala on monday
but it's going to be virtual so only
room for zoom
however then we're told that the vice
president will travel to the northern
triangle
in june but it's been 29 days since she
was tapped to lead the administration's
response to the crisis
and still no news conference we can't
even ask her any questions about this
it's really unbelievable again that
either the president the vice president
has not gone down to the border now i
understand the president's busy the vice
president
should be down in that border
understanding what is going on talking
to the law enforcement
talking to the men and women talking to
the sheriffs talking to the ranchers
and understanding the impact that that
much illegal immigration
per month is having on those communities
down there
then she will be better armed to talk
with the northern triangle countries in
mexico and others
but to go into those discussions whether
it's on zoom or in person
without understanding without seeing and
feeling it on the border
makes absolutely no sense and
unfortunately
you know the men and women of the border
patrol know this they don't see her down
there they don't see leadership down
there
uh and it's it's it's a huge problem and
it's a loss of confidence in this
administration as it moves forward
chad wolf former acting dhs secretary
joining us today thank you
very much